what's up women lover great and
respecter Pat here I have found the most
despicable disgusting
hurtful man on the Internet this
this man has has guess how much respect
he has for women that's right zero no
respect
nada eating it weight and it hurts to
swatch I don't even want to show it to
you cuz it's hurtful I feel like it's my
duty it's my duty to show you this man
this damn it we need to get him banned
[ __ ] is right to speak this man needs to
be destroyed
I believe in freedom of speech but
whenever people have an opinion opposed
to mine I think they should be blocked
and deleted and put in prison Yanis
Cohen : Mick joins us now
Janis Corvin Mick look at this man
he might look cute he might look a
little chipper he might look like your
uncle
but this man more he's opinions his
opinions now live from Warsaw in Poland
morning welcome to you sir can you
explain to people in Britain please why
you believe women should be paid less
than men because they're weaker smaller
and less intelligent what I am I'm sorry
you are lying I never said that women
should yes I love his accent so much
it's goddamn beautiful he makes this
whole thing 10 times better I only said
that because they are shorter they are
weaker they are less intelligence they
are less aggressive and so on and so on
they less
by the way shorter men are gentlemen
blonde and more than the brunettes the
differences the difference it should not
be equalized are you saying women are
not shot to the man with the grazing
world we live in
Yakima's my wife okay can you just give
me an example of where a short man earns
less than a tall man well I'm not
defending this on respecting women men
but I there what's the studies on it I
don't know if New York Times is a good
source but they did show that short men
make less than told me hey and I also
showed I think I was to show that bald
men made less money than people with
hair but I'm not defending this man okay
I'm merely giving some context so the it
is text it is proved and women earn less
because they are and so on and so let me
ask you the G person let me ask you do
you personally believe that women are
less what is that face it looks so
disgusted let me ask you now do you
personally believe that what is that did
you understand that when you say that
you're basically you understand that
when you say that on International
Women's Day what you're really doing is
showing the world that you are just a
horrendous sexist pig oh there that's
right peers get that disrespecting women
man make me angry it should be hue you
are not interested that the women are
solitary or the week is unmanned and so
of course they are less intelligence is
several poems on IQ scale of course they
are less intelligent disgusting how
could you say such a disgust no Deftones
it
but but please when you say women please
don't
at least he's saying please Pierce this
is like shush shush I have to speak you
are disrespecting women god bless you
Pierce be quiet you are disrespecting
women and I need you to be quiet be
intelligent and main how can you say
that women are less intelligent Amer
when you yourself sound so unbelievably
stupid
oh yeah um Pierce you are so dumb
oh hello darkness my old friend I've
come to talk with you again because
you're too stupid Oh double critical
damage how can you say that women are
less intelligent than men when you are
saying something yeah how can you say
that when you yourself say such stupid
things first of all how he talks it's so
beautiful it really rolls off the tongue
doesn't it first of all it is you're
saying a stupid you it is scientifically
proved and you say that what is
scientists determined you say a stupid
thing
well it's only so that you are idiots
boom strike back don't believe in
science and please don't don't mix up
don't mixing ups the women are less
intelligent son man I like this little
texture shows up here says women should
be paid less than men or you are lying I
never said that the women should yes no
that's it it doesn't matter what he says
that's that's the fact they here
I speak to miss Jenny see what Pierce is
doing here he is giving the women a
platform to speak he is not just taking
every word for himself he realizes let
my lady would you like to open your
mouth and have opinion as well because
you can because I respect you as a lady
I think might take exception to almost
everything you've just said so I find it
absolutely fascinating can I just
establish your credentials you you're a
member of the European Parliament what
right hell yeah
I mean no and what I don't understand
what I would agree that in cases that
women are physically weaker than men I
don't understand how you can possibly
justify a pay gap on the fact that women
are shorter than men because whatever
your argument that is just complete
rubbish how tall you 5 foot 4 right
there we go got'em that's my man Pearce
that's all are you fight it for point
proven
got'em can argue with statistics when
you got one example quite the setup I am
sorry
you'll still be eating stereotypes
you've got some front what is happening
I have no idea but it's extremely
entertaining take your special brand of
celebration of of women is is struggling
a bit given your extraordinary private
life okay eight children by four
different women oh [ __ ]
Pearce did some digging on this man
apparently has eight children with four
different women obviously
obviously I'm the stupid let me stop no
you stop you stop talking because so
much stupidity and then if you're aware
of this because you're an incredibly
stable man is linked to intelligence do
you see it you see how it works it's
math religious Thanks
it's one of the most interesting
interviews I think I've ever witnessed
actually and I do feel like I sat on the
sidelines while two men discuss you're
aware man they sit on the sidelines I'm
G I mean no you think it's over oh it's
merely just because yes sorry yeah go on
but please let me say something if don't
say I never said that women should have
unless I'm only explaining to this video
feminists say Oh women earning less why
I'm explaining why the men how tall are
you
how - I don't know that one one meter
8089 that sounded like English to me
right by six foot okay it's quite
extraordinary to have a guy believably
dim if you're the final message for the
women of the world on International
Women's Day that you can talk to them
directly
what would you like to say yeah now the
first time I watch this my initial
reaction was holy [ __ ] this guy is
insane what the [ __ ] is he saying
how can he say these things it's it's he
is definitely sexist but second time I
watched it
interpreting hole his stumbling and
mumbling I understand what he's trying
to say he like you said many times he's
not saying women should earn less he's
saying they are because of these reasons
and like I said I don't know if there's
a statistic that show that women are in
general or less intelligent than men and
if there is I would say what's the
[ __ ] point I feel like I'm sort of in
there in another corner in this
discussion he's basically saying there
is a gender gap because these reasons
Piers Morgan is saying there is a gender
gap and you're disgusting I'm saying
there is no gender gap it's been it's
been debunked several times now I'm
probably not the right person to talk
about this but the gender gap is
something that a lot of people you
probably heard about that women earn
less than men today the typical woman
who works full-time earns 79 cents for
every dollar that a typical man makes
it's definitely not a statement made so
that people can pat themselves on the
back and it's not a it's not a statement
that men make to further themselves in
different areas say politics what they
did with the gender gap is said they
took old men and old women and did a
median on it and said oh okay women earn
this amount less than men in general but
they don't take an account is well
pretty much anything at all like women
working less hours women choosing less
high paying jobs and so on and so forth
now if you take these factors into
account basically the gender gap comes
out to pretty much nothing because men
and women are paid generally equal
because it is governed by the law you
can't pay someone less money because of
their gender it's illegal it's been
illegal for 45 years if women were paid
less than men then why does all
companies just hire women you would have
to pay them less for the same job but
this statement lives on because
politicians like wants to further
himself people want to feel better by
saying it
oh we're mad people want to pat
themselves on the back but really you're
doing more harm than good by making
statements like this
now basically what the man was saying
there's more than one pay gap if you're
shorter you get paid less if you are
less intelligent you're more likely to
get paid less if you are fat you you are
likely to get paid less all these
different things all these different
privileges they all come down to to
license less pay but beers so
desperately wants to show that he's a
good man
that he's irrational he won't even like
listen to what he said he said several
times I don't think women should get
paid less hi those I never said that
women should nevertheless he said what
like what three times but you completely
ignored because Pierce so desperately
wants to show I'm standing up for women
it's so easy it's so easy to just be
like oh you're just red you're
disrespecting women you're disgusting
sexist pig but you're in the Parliament
get this man out of the Parliament let's
dismiss everything else this man
believes him because he's sexist and
disgusting what was the point of this
video
absolutely nothing I should probably I
feel like I should probably drop this
whole mean with whamon for a while
before Wall Street makes another montage
of all the stuff together let me top
final closing thought on this video if
you're female watching this I want you
to know that you are not what the media
or politicians or people on Twitter
trying to tell you or even what I am
trying to say you're not weak you are
not less privileged you are strong I
think it's such an unhealthy way of
looking at things what what happened -
I'm a woman hear me roar it's it's
become I'm a woman I earn less than men